[Musique]
en direct sur figaro live on attend vos
points de vue vous le savez pour
alimenter nos débats du jour est
aujourd'hui pour débattre nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir
sophie de menthon bout jour en jour chef
d'entreprise et présidente du mouvement
patronal ethic et face à vous adrien
matou journaliste politique à marianne
je rappelle que vous êtes également
l'auteur de mélenchon la chute comment
la france
insoumise s'est effondré qui est paru
aux éditions du rocher en octobre 2020
merci à tous les deux d'être avec nous
faut-il rayer le nucléaire de la carte
du monde
les écologistes en rêve depuis la
catastrophe de fukushima
c'est ce qu'écrivait sait ce qu'est
c'est ce qu'écrivait ce matin dans
l'éditorial du figaro gaëtan de capèle
fukushima c'était il ya dix ans jour
pour jour le 11 mars 2011
une vague de près de 15 mètres de haut
causée par un tsunami endommage
gravement la centrales nucléaires
côtières de fukushima au japon
cet événement causée par une catastrophe
naturelle et non pas par une défaillance
technique va marquer une cassure dans le
développement de l'industrie de l'atome
dans le monde alors nucléaire doit-on
vraiment en sortir c'est le thème de
notre débat et c'est aussi la question
qu'on vous pose sur twitter pensez vous
qu'il faille sortir du nucléaire on
attend votre participation et on vous
révélera vos votes
à la fin de ce premier débat sophie de
menthon c'est vers vous que je me tourne
en premier le nucléaire est une des
sources d'électricité les moins carboné
dont dispose la france
est-ce que selon vous aujourd'hui le
nucléaire a sa place parmi les énergies
renouvelables comme le solaire l'éolien
les loyers les éoliennes et
l'hydraulique le nucléaire à sa place
c'est très clair et je suis d'autant
plus à l'aise pour le dire que j'ai été
contre le nucléaire de façon
irrationnelle j'avais peur parce que ça
me paraissait très dangereuse c'est
toujours des erreurs humaines qui
peuvent arriver et qui provoquent des
catastrophes
et puis quand il ya une catastrophe
nucléaire on rigole pas c'est pas ces
parias cela dit vous avez parfaitement
raison de préciser que c'est un tsunami
qui a été dramatique qui a causé ce
drame absolu qui aurait causé
probablement largement autonome
c'est pas le nucléaire alors évidemment
ça a dévasté la région après etc
mais c'est le tsunami qui auraient causé
ces morts et donc je pense que le
nucléaire d'abord une erreur
fondamentale parler du nucléaire ça veut
rien dire il ya le nucléaire
maintenant on arrive à faire des petites
centrales locales incroyable pour
chauffer des villes c'est ce que fait
rolls royce figurez-vous qu'il fait des
petites centrales qu'ils enterrent et
qui éclaire et chauffe des villes c'est
plus ce nucléaire qu'on imaginait c'est
beaucoup plus facile c'est parce qu'une
énergie d'ailleurs assez fier lemoine au
moins effrayant on est capable de
beaucoup moins effrayant effrayant quant
au fameux déchets vous savez qu'ils
tiendraient dans une piscine donc je
suis alors bon j'ai beaucoup regardé
tout ça parce que parce que j'avais peur
ou alors dit vous n'avez plus peur un
peu moins adriana tout le réchauffement
climatique on sait que c'est une menace
pour notre environnement pour l'avenir
de la planète
on est face à une urgence climatique et
du coup le nucléaire at il a une carte à
jouer
désormais face à cette urgence or non
seulement il a une carte à jouer pour
moi c'est la carte à jouer c'est à dire
que en fait on présente toujours comme
incompatibles le fait de vouloir réduire
notre production d'énergie enfin notre
me notre consommation et le fait
d'utiliser le nucléaire
en fait on peut faire les deux
d'ailleurs que moi je pense
qu'effectivement il faut aller vers un
mode de vie plus sobres mais je pense
que pour limiter la brutalité de cette
transition là les nucléaire c'est la
meilleure solution pourquoi alors on
vous l'avez dit vous l'avez très bien
dit c'est une énergie extrêmement
décarbonés la fission d'un gramme de
nucléaire produit autant d'énergie que
la combustion de une tonne de pétrole
et si on prend vous savez le l'unité de
référence et le kilowatt/heure santé
c'est l'unité des références de
l'énergie pour produire un kilo watt
heure avec du nucléaire ça produit 6
grammes de co2
ces dix grammes de co2 pour l'éolien et
ses 50 grammes pour le solaire c'est
bien nous donner des chiffres aussi
précis mais on va aussi de pas noyer
bien sûr gens qui nous regardent si
c'est moins cher vous vous parler du mot
cher vous parlez du kilowattheure
justement et le coût du nucléaire est un
problème il coûte cher ce nucléaire et à
produire et aussi de la facture de ceux
qui s'en servent
on est face aujourd'hui à une
concurrence ddm
renouvelables qui sont de plus en plus
accessible de moins en moins cher est-ce
que du coup le nucléaire peut arriver le
nucléaire est pas si cher que ça
finalement ils arrivent à chauffer parce
qu'il ya des frais à des pleins de
choses annexes dans les coûts des
énergies renouvelables aussi ça n'oblige
pas vraiment sortir son épingle du jeu à
huy façon et sans compter que ces
énergies renouvelables sont
complémentaires on peut très bien
imaginer d'en faire aussi c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire d'ailleurs veolia et
edf etc
alors maintenant si on voulait faire
j'ai regardé parce que c'est parlant si
on voulait remplacer par des éoliennes
par tout ce qu'on peut faire de
différent du nucléaire en france à
couvrir et quatre départements français
quatre départements français du bidule
pour faire d'électricité pour produire
la même quantité d'énergie est le
nucléaire ça prend cinq cents fois plus
d espace avec le solaire explique
d'ailleurs ces essais c'est vrai le
nucléaire dénature - les paysages
puisque les énergies renouvelables comme
vous le dites a dream à tous occupent
beaucoup d espace vous pensez que c'est
un argument qui a du poids selon de vous
dans le choix d'aller ou d'abandonner le
nucléaire
selon moi c'est un point fondamental
mais il ya un deuxième argument qu'on
n'a pas encore donné c'est que le
nucléaire est une énergie pilotable
c'est à dire qu'on peut la gérer
or le principal défaut des énergies
renouvelables c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
encore philo table serre que ça veut
dire pilota pilotable ça veut dire qu'au
gré du vent
voilà juste il n'y a pas de soleil on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas en fait utilisé
l'énergie qu'on aurait stocké au
préalable pour le
pour pour parer aux besoins de
consommation alors que le nucléaire on
peut le gérer avec beaucoup de précision
donc en gros
évidemment qu'il faut avoir du
renouvelable dans le mix énergétique
il faut utiliser ces énergies mais
seulement en complément parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et malheureusement
ça arrive beaucoup dans notre pays s'il
ya près de soleil ou s'il ya peu de vent
eh ben on ne peut rien faire on reste
quand même l'éolien marin il reste vous
ne pouvez pas sur milo ne pouvaient pas
couvrir les besoins énergétiques d'un
pays comme la france uniquement avec des
éoliennes et du solaire ça ne peut
qu'être du complément en somme vous
pouvez choisir le charbon plutôt que lui
clair c'est votre choix vous aurez
beaucoup plus de co2 beaucoup plus de
co2 donc ça va même les allemands des
cartes de l'arbre est beaucoup plus cher
leur électricité que nous les allemands
et les écolos allemands sont maintenant
pour le nucléaire n'est quand même pas
un
un petit pas de leurs pas donc en disant
il soit environ nouveau changer d'avis
votre avis adrien matou est le vôtre
aussi sophie de menthon berges ou un peu
celui de patrick sur youtube qui nous
dit pour utiliser quel autre mode que le
nucléaire aucun système ne peut
rivaliser
actuellement avec l'énergie nucléaire à
coeur sur youtube l'énergie nucléaire
est une énergie d'avenir seulement on
l'a mal gérée mal conçue et mal
entretenu on n'a pas non plus penser au
recyclage des matériaux une fois
appauvrissez effectivement maintenant
l'avenir des déchets nucléaires n'a
trouvé mais c'est hollande qui a arrêté
sa il y avait un système on prenait les
déchets pour produire de l'énergie
ça s'appelait j'ai oublié c'était c'est
un système incroyable mais il à arrêter
ça et je pense que ça c'est un problème
qui a été à peu créé par les écoliers il
faut quand même préciser que la question
des déchets on entend beaucoup parler de
déchets oui alors déjà sophie l'a dit
les déchets produits par le nucléaire
depuis son lancement en france tient
dans une piscine mais en plus il y
aurait des problèmes à échéance deux
cent mille ans on n'est même pas sûr que
l'espèce humaine existe encore dans son
bilan en fait je crois que ce qui
faisait polémique à quelques années
c'est qu'on était aussi nous
les nettoyeurs des déchets d'autres pays
producteurs de nucléaire comme le japon
et c'est ce qui avait créé des incidents
sur les transports de ces matériaux à à
nettoyer à retraités chez edf pour
réduire la facture
justement le coût de ce nucléaire on
envisage une standardisation de la
construction de futurs réacteurs hop et
r c'est à dire que n'oublie flamanville
le on va dire ce désastre économique et
le coup qu'a représenté le développement
de cette prs qu'on peut y croire cet
état d'asie standardisation de ces
futurs rpr et une facilité à à
construire ces centrales nucléaires à
venir moi j'y crois
sans tomber dedans vous avez vu les
progrès et l'image ce qu'on peut faire
et puis on a on a une image centrales
nucléaires avec des boutons on appuie
extraits ci plus du tout ça yahia de
cette miniaturisation des centrales
nucléaires je pense que c'est tout le
monde a tellement travaillé sur ce sujet
que la réponse est oui évidemment les
progrès sont énormes en la matière non
mais surtout on a fait quand même
beaucoup sur le prix du nucléaire il
faut quand même préciser que le le coup
l'électricité en france sachant qu'en
france électricité c'est à 90% du
nucléaire les français paient leur
électricité beaucoup moins cher que les
autres pays européens
justement grâce au nucléaire mais qu'il
faut arrêter de mépriser la chaîne
d'électricité parce que ils ont du
charbon et nous pollue mais nous a
peut-être le principal danger pour le
nucléaire en france c'est le
démantèlement d'edf qui est prévue avec
le projet recul et de la commission
européenne ce a effectivement ça peut ça
peut mettre en danger le mix énergétique
est ce que ça veut dire que si on se
séparait du nucléaire ont en tout cas
qu'il entrait pour un moindre
pourcentage dans la production
d'électricité en france on aurait des à
terme des factures d'électricité vous
disait que nos factures étaient peu
élevés par rapport à nos voisins
européens et même à l'étranger on parle
rsa on a parlé récemment des coupures de
courant dramatique aux états unis suite
à l'énorme vague de froid est aussi des
des factures d'électricité qu'ils
avaient à payer en notamment au texas
est ce que nous on devrait craindre ce
type d'explosion de factures
d'électricité sur passer au tout
renouvelable
or nucléaire en fait vous avez trois
options soit vous avez la facture qui
monte en ayant la même consommation soit
vous avez des vous passer à un mode de
vie que je qualifierais de moyenâgeux
c'est à dire que vous compenser le fait
depuis lors le nucléaire en vous
basé sur ce qui accule renouvelables
mais ce n'est pas assez soit c'est le
co2 qui explose parce qu'on remplace le
nucléaire par le charbon comme le font
les allemands
donc après voilà c'est mon choix enfin
c'est un retour en arrière absolument
incroyable sur le remplacer par le
charbon c'est une imagination des cimes
elle était prise justement dans la
foulée de vrai que la catastrophe de
fukushima fois on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une erreur dans la prise de décisions
et en tout cas moi qui représente un peu
les chefs d'entreprise veut dire que
tout les chefs d'entreprise tous les
chefs d'entreprise sont pro nucléaire
parce que bat plus pour les usines qu'on
essaie de redévelopper en france pour
toute l'industrie
il est évident que c'est pas du tout la
même chose que le coût de l'énergie pour
se chauffer quand vous avez des usines à
faire marcher et cetera donc oui tout le
monde économique et pour le nucléaire
mais c'est assez intéressant cet aspect
sportif parce que cette salle illustre
bien le caractère de l'opposition au
nucléaire en france c'est à dire que on
a l'impression que c'est à la base c'est
une opposition qui est largement basée
sur l'opposition au nucléaire militaire
qu'il est basé sur la voie là évidemment
il y aura shima nagasaki c'est pas la
meilleure pub pour le nucléaire et on a
l'impression qu'on joue à se faire peur
entre tchernobyl c'est arrivé ça n'a pas
été une catastrophe en termes de vies
humaines mais même si c'est une
catastrophe industrielle mais on a une
opposition au nucléaire qui est
largement basée sur l'irrationalité et
j'ai envie de dire sur une forme
d'obscurantisme parce que tous les
arguments rationnels sont quand même
pour un maintien du nucléaire
je ne pourrais pas quand même rappeler
le tchernobyl en 86 ça y est restée dans
les mémoires sur encore très présents
aujourd'hui c'est encore très présent
mais par exemple il ya une
l'hydroélectricité qui est une forme de
production d'électricité qui ne qui ne
déclenche quasiment aucune critique et
ben qui sait que dans les années 70 en
chine il ya eu 1 1 par âge un accident
avec un barrage qui a fait plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de morts
c'est par rapport à tchernobyl c'est
absolument considérable et on n'entend
pas répéter ad nauseam c'est
l'épisode de cet accident donc il ya un
côté irrationnel avec la peur du
nucléaire souvent je trouve que les
militants antinucléaires ne mobilise pas
des arguments basés sur la raison c'est
un petit peu dommage
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a les moyens de
les états ont les moyens de faire la
fine bouche face au nucléaire
quand on voit les enjeux que représente
d'urgence climatique une nouvelle fois
d'abord il isolé moyenne dire des
bêtises ça c'est partout c'est très
étonnant à l'allemagne ses décisions
parce que quand même il s'en mordre les
doigts a finalement il ya des tas de
pays qui avaient abandonné qui
recommence c'est très intéressant de
voir tient dans challenges la la carte
des centrales nucléaires celles qui vont
disparaître qui se construisent et en
fait la chine s'y est mis il a par
contre nucléaire c'est le seul continent
qui qu'ici mais je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse échapper au nucléaire aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire que le monde a besoin
de l'atome pour parvenir à décarbonés
l'ensemble de la planète selon moi oui
alors évidemment il faut pas qu'on sort
des stands des centrales sur des failles
sismiques
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure idée et
on est je trouve qu'en plus on constate
que l'abandon du nucléaire c'est souvent
des des enjeux politiciens qui les
terminent par exemple les allemands
l'ont fait parce que les écolos avaient
beaucoup de poids en france françois
hollande a diminué le nucléaire parce
qu'il voulait faire un accord avec les
écolos les écolos pour eux c'est quelque
chose d'identitaires l'opposition au
nucléaire et pourront pas reculer dessus
c'est quasiment ce qui a fondé leur
existence mais de voir l'attitude
d'emmanuel macro parce que je comprends
pas il est évidemment pro nucléaire il
souffle le chaud et le froid
oui et donc indéfiniment mais c'est pas
une bonne solution de souffler le chaud
et le froid sur et en plus on a fait
cette convention là où on a carrément
sorti le nucléaire du sujet parce que
vous voulez pas fâché non
donc il n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait et
on peut pas perdu en même temps là donc
c'est toujours d'actualité puisque le
mix énergétique ambitionné par la france
ça sera 50% nucléaire à l'échéance 2035
mais aujourd'hui à 70 %
donc on va réduire la voir clair qu'on
peut voir en ambitionne de réduire la
part de l'énergie décarbonée et peu
chères dans notre mix énergétique ce qui
est quand même un objectif un petit peu
curieux mais ça sera votre conclusion je
vais vous citer juste 2
commentaires d'internautes baptiste il
n'y a pas de véritable sur youtube il
n'y a pas de véritable alternative
viable pour le moment et shooter sur
youtube sortir du nucléaire pour ouvrir
des centrales à charbon et planter des
éoliennes on recycle amont strict
massivement en chine qui détruisent la
faune et la flore est d'une débilité
sans nom pensez vous qu'il faille sortir
du nucléaire c'est la question que vous
posez sur twitter et vous êtes
évidemment on s'en doutait presque 80% à
dire que non il ne faut pas vous dire
que ça a changé
c'est incroyable parce que la population
a terriblement évolué c'était la moitié
il ya dix ans mais c'est là c'est parce
que l'accident et la catastrophe de
fukushima avait refroidi totalement
rabab le mans
notre ambition de développer le
nucléaire un peu plus et le côté vert de
cette énergie sur beaucoup d'aspects est
passé à la trappe
on passe à notre deuxième débat du jour
marine le pen est elle une candidate
comme une autre ou une candidate comme
les autres c'est la question que vous
pose sur twitter pensez vous que marine
le pen est une candidate comme les
autres on attend votre participation et
vous donnera votre pourcentage de
participation à la fin de ce débat selon
un sondage et lab relayé par bfmtv dater
de ce 11 mars près d'un français sur
deux estiment probable la victoire de
marine le pen à l'élection
présidentielle en 2022
par ailleurs une enquête menée par
harris interactive le 8 mars dernier
pour comme strates et l'opinion donne
emmanuel macron vainqueur du scrutin de
mais le score est serré au second tour
50 3% des voix pour emmanuel macron et
47% pour la candidate du rassemblement
national
ce même sondage révèle également que le
front républicain cette union politique
ce barrage contre le pen est en train de
s'effondrer
sophie de menthon ses résultats
d'opinion sont ils pour vous le signe
d'une banalisation achevé abouti de
marine le pen c'est une dédiabolisation
réussie de la part de marine le pen et
c'est un peu une réussite parce que elle
devient peu
non pas fréquentable fréquentable dans
l'esprit des électeurs
alors maintenant pardonnez moi je suis
très agacé par ce sujet parce parce que
d'abord on est à un an et demi on a de
tels problèmes aux entreprises qui
doivent redémarrer les vaccins et
caetera et on est en train de nous jouer
l'élection présidentielle avec le fameux
duel qui fait trembler les médias et
j'arrive pas beaucoup à m'intéresser à
ce fameux duel qui va il ya tout est
possible en anonyme on vit vraiment une
période difficile tout est possible
alors ou non je n'ai pas très peur de
marine le pen
sauf sur un seul point j'ai très très
peur d'elle à des connaissances
économiques de marine le pen
j'ai l'impression que ça sur le plan
économique ce serait une véritable
catastrophe je n'arrive pas à savoir si
elle est à droite à gauche communiste où
elle se situe c'est pas si sûr parce
qu'elle vise la clientèle mêlant
chaînistes quatrième à tous et une
normalisation marine le pen ces chiffres
qui sont donnés depuis quelques semaines
incontestablement
mais ceci dit c'est un processus de long
terme sauf il est un petit peu dit c'est
à dire qu'il ya mais met d'ailleurs ça
ne se mesure pas qu'à ce sondage parce
que si vous rappeler les élections
européennes c'était calme en 2019
laura ce moment nationale est arrivée en
tête sans que cela provoque des émotions
particulières
vous avez aussi les municipales plus
récemment où il ya quand même quasiment
tous les maires et rennes sortant ont
gagné leur élection et le merengue a
gagné dix villes comme perpignan sans
que cela provoque voilà de
manifestations dans la rue comme c'était
le cas en 2002 quand jean-marie le pen
est est qualifié au second tour il ya
deux facteurs de dédiabolisation le
prométhée sur le long terme ou
effectivement marine le pen depuis
qu'elle a succédé à son père est là elle
a un petit peu récupéré une rhétorique
républicaine laïque alors certes en la
dénaturant mais ça a contribué à
normaliser le fn elle a aussi un petit
peu expurgé le parti de ces éléments les
plus extrémistes et plus récemment alors
en fait ce qui est assez amusant c'est
de voir que le rn est quand même
toujours assez radical sur le sujet
d'identité par exemple c'est quand même
un parti qui veut interdire le port du
voile dans la rue il ya toujours la
préférence nationale il ya toujours un
risque
random sur la peine de mort mais c'est
pas ça qui semblé émouvoir notamment la
droite et par exemple l'intervention de
sophie l'illustré un peu c'était plutôt
sur les grands sujets économiques
elle faisait peur qu'on avait peur
qu'elle soit la peine de mort ça c'est
du rail quand même oui mais en tout cas
c'était intéressant parce que moi je
vous dis je vois qu'à droite c'était
toujours le discours où la marine le pen
bon le fait qu'elle aime pas les
immigrés c'est pas grave mais ce qui
nous fait peur c'est qu'elle soit
contrôle euros c'est qu'elle veuille le
fric sites extérieurs qu'il ya un truc
que je voudrais absolument c'est que le
fn soit représenté à l'assemblée
nationale c'est inimaginable de voir un
chiffre de gens qui à 48% ou lui ou
l'imaginent ou pourrait voter pour elle
et connaît une assemblée nationale qui
naquit n'a pas comporte pas de députés
afin de passer c'est pas démocratique
c'est honteux
ouais mais alors sur ce sujet économique
c'est intéressant de voir qu'elles se
normalisent aussi wisair qu'elle est là
abandonné le fric site
elle est pour le nucléaire en fait oui
je crois qu'elle lui pour le nucléaire
la wii elle a abandonné la sortie de
l'euro oui là elle a fait une tribune
pour dire qu'il fallait pas s'opposer au
remboursement de la dette
donc je pense qu'il ya une volonté de sa
part d'essayer de de modérer son image
sur le plan économique alors
effectivement on risque de décevoir
l'électorat populaire qui la soutient
encore massivement mais il ya une
tentative de normalisation sur les deux
sur l'écologie également un pied sur
l'écologie aussi elle a proposé quelque
chose à intégrer dans son programme à
venir
jean luc mélenchon a dit a indiqué
dimanche dernier 7 mars qui ne donnerait
pas de consignes de vote en cas de duel
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
au second tour de la présidentielle de
2000 22 depuis quelques semaines au
détour de sondages on en a parlé on nous
révèle les réticences d'une partie des
électeurs de la gauche a voté pour
emmanuel macron en cas de duel avec
marine le pen au second tour de la
présidentielle et certains y voient une
porosité réel entre une partie de
l'électorat de gauche et le
rassemblement national
est ce qu'une partie de l'électorat de
gauche sophie nantes pourrait voter pour
marine le pen
alors je connais pas très bien les
lecteurs à gauche et je ne sais pas très
bien de quoi il est composé aujourd'hui
parce que la gauche ne sait plus très
bien ce que c'est non plus marquée la
droite eut pas beaucoup plus à l'aise
mais ce que je sais c'est que ce sont
des extrémistes
mélenchon pour moi est un extrémiste il
ya un excellent livre qui explique
comment il s'est tu on espère qu'il va
ressusciter
je pense que d'abord aussi les consignes
de vote quelque chose d'archaïque c'est
un tic de langage il
personne qui obéit à une consigne de
vote lui dire quand vous avez la tension
vous réfléchissez un petit peu et vous
suivez votre sensibilité
donc le fait qu'on dise je donnerai pas
de consigne de vote
ça veut dire que l'on déteste macron et
que on accepte marine le pen vaguement
mais c'est tout non ma touche précise
simplement que sophie de menthon faisait
référence à votre livre évidemment
journal gentil alors sur les électeurs
de gauche
alors jean marc et jean luc mélenchon a
déjà en 2017 avait refusé de choisir
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
il ya une partie des acteurs de
mélenchon qui pourraient voter pour
marine le pen je la qualifierais pas
d'extrémistes je la qualifierais de
populiste ce qui est un petit peu
différent non en fait il faut pas
exagérer parce que c'est pas beaucoup
d'électeurs de mélenchon qui voteraient
pour marine le pen
non c'est marine le pen l'emportent au
second tour contre emmanuel macron c'est
parce que les électeurs de gauche
s'abstiendront ou voteront blanc c'est
pas parce qu'ils vont voter pour marine
le pen c'est à dire que en gros le jeu
de la droite va voter pour marine le pen
avait est ce que marine le pen pourrait
exploiter cet électorat de gauche auprès
alors moi je pense que tout son jeu est
d'ailleurs j'ai un très bon papier de
mon collègue le docteur qu'il explique
dans marianne je fais un peu de promo
tout le jeu de marine le pen c'est de ne
pas trop paraître comme extrémistes pour
que les gens de gauche ne fasse pas trop
la différence entre elle et mâcon
puisque emmanuel macron c'est quand même
beaucoup droitiser dans son image depuis
son élection comme président et vous
avez tout un électorat de gauche qui
quand même se dit bon est-ce que je vais
vraiment me mobiliser pour faire barrage
au fascisme
sachant que marine le pen n'est
peut-être pas celle ci aimerait
également rembourser justement je dis ça
avec un peu de dire oui parce que ces
gens là vont se dire ce genre on le
refait le coup du barrage au fascisme
tous les cinq ans quand même et vous il
on se dit ah bon marine le pen n'est
peut-être pas vraiment fasciste c'est ce
qu'il va essayer de montrer et emmanuel
macron n'est peut-être pas si différent
d'elle quand vous avez gérald darmanin
qui dit à marine le pen qu'elle est
qu'ils volent c'est le genre de chose
qui fait turbiner le cerveau d'un
électeur de gauche et je peux vous dire
que emmanuel macron qui s'est beaucoup
droitiser dans son image dans sa
politique
il devrait se méfier quand même parce
que effectivement nous on avait fait une
enquête sur sa dans marianne il ya
beaucoup de gens de gauche qui se disent
non on va pas me refaire le coup
le no pasaran ça ne marchera pas cette
fois-ci petit onnaing sur youtube on
peut changer d'emballage le produit à
l'intérieur le produit à l'intérieur
reste le même nicole nous dit quand on
voit le nombre de députés la france un
soumise par rapport au rassemblement
national ce n'est pas représentatif des
électeurs je pense qu'elle fait
référence aux députés à l'assemblée
nationale
alexandre sur youtube elle a ses idées
marine le pen ses convictions son
programme les 500 signatures qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas c'est une candidate
parisien tête de chien c'est le portrait
de cet internaute
les français sont économiquement à
gauche malheureusement donc le
rassemblement national va dans ce sens
c'est pourquoi
marion maréchal a claqué la porte moi
moi moi je fais une petite parenthèse
parce que ce qui est très étonnant il y
aura eu au moins est bien fait de cette
pandémie horrible c'est que l'entreprise
tout d'un coup et est apparue comme
capable salvatrice
c'est un recours et la réconciliation
des français avec l'entreprise
alors est-ce qu'elle n'a pas été sauvée
plutôt que salvatrice l'entreprise par
l'état pendant la pandémie
alors c'est une très bonne réflexion
elle a été d'une part sauver mais elle a
été salvatrice aussi parce que si on
n'avait pas sauvé ce serait une
catastrophe et je voudrais revenir sur
le fait que tout ce qu'on a trouvé tout
ce qu'on a fait et y compris noces à des
entreprises du mouvement ethic que je
représente
qui c'est le privé qui a installé des
centres de vaccination qui a apporté des
masques qui a transformé ses usines pour
faire du gel donc là tout d'un coup
quand même les
et puis les salariés ont trouvé que
c'était pas si mal d'aller au bureau
romain vu le nombre de français à sortir
la carte du tout sauf macron ça va bien
finir par la faire passer et la faire
accepter
est-ce qu'on surestime pas un peu trop
justement le potentiel présidentiable de
la chef du rassemblement national
peut-être pour se faire peur mais mais
en fait tout toutes ces réflexions
si on descend très un petit peu le
regard c'est quand même intéressant de
voir que dans tous les pays d'europe
il est toujours quasiment toujours en
tout cas un parti populiste de droite
qui émergent et qui vient et qui souvent
et on voit en portant des aspirations
aller en gros anti-immigration c'est
quand même sur ça que ça se fait en
majorité vous avez mais il ya une
spécificité du
dur à son maintien en france air que au
royaume uni vous avez you keep et les
conservateurs en espagne vous avez vox
en italie vous avez les gars et en
allemagne vous avez l'afd la seule
différence c'est qu'en france ce n'est
pas un nouveau parti vert que tous ces
partis là s'est dé nouveau parti s'est
départi jeunes or le fn maintenant le fn
c'est un parti qui objectivement a été
fondée par des fascistes c'est sale
c'est ça la reine c'est un parti qui
objectivement a été fondée par des
pétainistes par des gens d'extrême
droite et c'est un petit peu ça s'écoute
et sulfureux qui peut être l'empêchent
d'accéder au pouvoir parce que les idées
qu'on les ait qu'on les apprécie ou pas
les idées de marine le pen aujourd'hui
sont fort bien représenté dans parmi les
français voire majoritaire et peut-être
que la marche qui manquent à marine le
pen pour être élu c'est ce côté
sulfureux dont elle aura de dotation du
mal à se débarrasser rapidement temps
une réaction par rapport à ce stade rien
à tous l'analyse est assez juste
ce qui est amusant c'est que finalement
le nouveau le parti etc
c'était macro d'ailleurs il avait joué
là dessus je me souviens avoir une
discussion avec lui avant qu'il se
présente et c'est fini les parties
regarder il me suit lé même pays que
vous est il disait il y à il ya besoin
d'un renouveau c'est fini les vieux
partis classiques
il a réussi son pari bon
pour être élue je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
ait raté parce qu'on va voir comment ça
se passe maintenant parce que c'est
quand même fondamental l'année qui va
venir
s'il réussit les vaccins à la reprise de
l'économie etc ben je pense qu'il a ses
chances donc très difficile macro
d'évidence est plutôt à droite plutôt
libérale mais il est extrêmement prudent
il est un peu en même temps ce qui moi
me dérange
voilà je n'arrive pas à voir marine le
pen à la tête du pays on va revenir à
elle justement quand il ya quelques
jours chez nos confrères d'europe 1 la
présidente du rassemblement national
marine le pen s'est agacé de
l'expression ennemis de la république
utilisé à son encontre
en disant cela fait des années qu'on
nous sort cette litanie on n'a jamais eu
un élément précis nous ne sommes pas les
ennemis de la république nous sommes les
seuls protecteur aujourd'hui de la
république quelles réflexions sa défense
vous inspire-t-elle à la raison elle n'a
jamais été anti républicaine elle a eu
plein de défauts elle a eu des positions
racistes de temps en temps elle etc
mais moi je la trouve pas anti
républicaine craignent un matou qu'est
ce qui est rond et 15,4 anti républicain
c'est vouloir changer la forme du régime
m contre les élections
vouloir transformer la france en autre
chose qu'une république de ce point de
vue là le fn n'est pas anti républicain
sinon il faudrait interdire de se
présenter aux élections et on peut
considérer que c'est quand même une
ennemie de la république et moraliser
toujours des grands mots moi je ne pense
pas que marine le pen soit une année
mais la république je pense par contre
que dans son parti il ya beaucoup
d'aînés la république ou de gens qui
détestent la république qui font quelque
chose qui est fondamentalement contre la
république qui est de penser la
citoyenneté française en termes
ethniques et non pas en termes civique
ça c'est quelque chose
c'est vrai en tant que républicain on ne
peut que trouver ça abominable mais ce
n'est pas le cas de marine le pen marine
le pen se garde bien en tout cas de
faire la moindre déclaration qui
laisserait penser qu'elle défend une
france blanche ou qu'elle veut s'en
prendre spécifiquement aux gens raison
de leur couleur de certains considèrent
c'est une stratégie justement c'est
difficile de sonder les âmes et de voir
ce qui se cache derrière stratégie ce
qui est vrai c'est marine le pen a
récupéré depuis une dizaine d'années le
vocabulaire de la laïcité et de la
république qui n'était pas du tout en
cours au fn c'est à dire que c'est des
gens que la référence à la république ça
leur donner des boutons elle elle en a
fait un élément de la liste d'ailleurs
pratiquement voilà elle a faim il en a
fait un élément de langage fondamentale
quitte à dénaturer d'ailleurs la laïcité
à en faire un instrument identitaire
dirigée contre les musulmans ou islam
mais en tout cas
symboliquement elle toute sa stratégie
c'est de se faire passer pour celle qui
défend la république et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que alors ce fameux
duel le pen macro nov il paraît que la
seule à pouvoir casser ce duel serait
anne hidalgo alors parisien 7h sur trois
temps est favorable maintenant lé
parisien tête de chien non plus pour
prendre votre guitare
mais je pense que anne hidalgo qui par
ailleurs est femme sympathique et
extrêmement dangereuse avec une capacité
à mener à bien ses propres décisions
quand elle a vu ce qu'elle a fait de
paris elle l'a voulu
elle l'a fait rien ne l'arrêté et je
trouve que elle pourrait créer la
surprise selon vous en tout cas à mon
avis aussi dangereuse que marine le pen
ah oui bon après là elle part de loin
elle a quand même à 6 % dans les
sondages elle part de loin
elle est stationnaire effectivement
jean-luc sur youtube nous dit si le
parti rassemblement rassemblement
national qu'elle dirige et est
antirépublicain il faudrait l'interdire
6 s'il ne l'est pas elle est de facto
une candidate à la présidentielle comme
les autres en fait ça pose la question
de la manière de se poser au
rassemblement national pourquoi le et
rennes monte depuis des années notamment
parce que ceux qui s'y opposent et
malheureusement beaucoup à gauche se se
complaisent dans une forme d'anti
fascisme un peu d'opérette en disant
l'extrême droite arrive c'est comme
c'est comme en 1936 contre les ligues
d'extrême droite
il faut faire barrage etc sauf que quand
vous avez en face dirk en 1936 les
ligues 10 10 est effectivement il faut
il faut mettre à bas la république
le rn ne dit jamais ça et marine le pen
ne dit jamais ça donc au bout d'un
moment ce discours il n'est pas très
performant tiff et il ya une autre aile
droite que personne c'est ce que c'est
comme ça oui bah un concept démodé en
fait c'est plus que on utilise ce terme
pour désigner beaucoup de choses alors
il ya des gens pour qui l' extrême
droite commence au parti socialiste
faut le savoir donc au bout d'un moment
il ya une espèce de décalage entre la
réalité et les mots qu'on utilise pour
la décrire ce que vous dites est
intéressant parce que ça me fait penser
qu'il y a quelques années sur ce plateau
pas tout à fait mais en tout cas sur
figaro live au figaro didier barbelivien
en 2015 disait marine le pen n'est pas
d'extrême droite
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'extrêmement
ratisser moi je pose la question après
moi je vous dirais plutôt si vous me
demandez mon avis je dirais pas qu'elle
est d'extrême droite je dirais qu'elle
d'une droite dure une droite
nationaliste ça c'est vraiment triste
mais pas du souverainisme c'est partout
maintenant elle est en gros et moins
elle est beaucoup moins qu'avant
souveraineté moins qu'avant mais moi ce
qui me sidère c'est que tout le monde
est en train d'apprécier le retour des
frontières tout ça parce que le monde
est mis il faut fermer les frontières il
faut départ c'est assez stupéfiant c'est
tellement mouvant que la réalité peut
avoir des conséquences sur la définition
même de ces partis politiques pm 75
marine le pen n'a aucune crédibilité au
niveau économique
sa force c'est son discours sur
l'immigration non contrôlée
alors peut-être mais alors je me suis
fier comme un peu de ce discours sur la
crédibilité économique de marine le pen
c'est à dire que vous avez quand même
ballot
ce qui est vrai on ne pourra pas revenir
dessus c'est qu'elle a complètement raté
son débat interminable maquereau en 2017
et qu'elle a montré qu'elle ne
maîtrisait pas les termes économiques
par contre attention aux discours qui
est que dès que quelqu'un n'a pas un
discours libéral sur l'économie et des
qui défend l'intervention de l'état
ça y est il n'y a pas de crédibilité
c'est quand même un petit peu un petit
peu la technique oui dis que je préside
parce qu'on a reçues tous les candidats
et c'était étonnant parce que d'ailleurs
allez allez très très forte parce que la
façon d'éviter les sujets qu'elle ne
connaît pas aller très forte mais pour l
économie est là elle a pris un créneau
ses jeux des fois les petits commerçants
et défend les petits alors c'est le
petit commerçant
la pme etc locale
ça s'appelait aussi beaucoup il n'y a
pas grand monde pour défendre le 4 40 en
france vient tout seul
oui est donc allé à l'aise si dallas et
son petit chemin étroit pour l'économie
et on n'arrive pas à savoir on a posé
pas mal de questions n'arrive pas à
savoir le temps de travail la liberté
d'entreprendre
c'est pas un vocabulaire très compliqué
oui mais sophie si elle était si elle se
posait un petit peu à la liberté
d'entreprendre et qu'elle défendrait
plus je sais pas moi les céder les
droits des salariés ou la fonction
publique est ce que vous diriez qu'elle
est pas de même avec vous ou pas
crédible c'est quand même ça la question
oh je dirais surtout qu'elle n'est pas
du même avis que moi d'efforts de la
fonction publique il n'y a pas grand
monde l'actuel mort mais j'entre il
n'est pas sûr que ce soit le l'apanage
de la gauche elle est allez allez allez
quand même il ya un flou artistique
gigantesque il ya un flou sur le fn
parce que c'est pas c'est pas un élément
fondateur du fn le fn sont tous d'accord
sur l'immigration ils sont tous d'accord
sur la sécurité etc
mais l'autorité a pourtant les prisons
alors et moi je rejoins pas mal de
positions on va clore ce débat
bon pour mon dernier mot c'est que l à
l'actualité lui donnent souvent raison
que quand je vois ce qui se passe avec
des jeunes ce matin moi même qui suis
tout sauf d'extrême droite se disait bon
il faut des maisons de correction est
tout de suite à 14 ans on met pas un
moment tall on le met dans une maison de
correction où ils se lèvent le matin
encadrés par l'armée on essaie d'en
faire et ça me paraît beaucoup mieux
pour eux mais ça paraît peut-être
quelque chose de d'inimaginable mais
l'actualité va dans le sens de marine le
pen qui dirait passer facilement ça ça
sera le mot de la fin je dirais que la
rapidement le fait que la gauche
choisissent d'ignorer des problèmes
comme la sécurité comme migration que
soulève sophie porte préjudice dans la
lutte contre marine le pen
pensez vous que marine le pen est une
candidate comme les autres vous êtes 65%
à répondre oui à ces enseignants et 35%
à répondre non notre émission touche à
sa fin merci encore de nous avoir suivis
à très vite pour d'autres points de vue
et à très vite sur figaro live
[Musique]